but my biggest prediction for 2021 is
you're going to see
the porn industry adopt crypto big time
that is my big prediction of point we're
gonna have only fans but but with crypto
is that what you think well what
because what happened was so much
mastercard and visa
dumped pornhub they said we don't we
they cut ties at one hour right so
pornhub
being the winegate being the biggest
pawn company in the world
they had to fix that real quick smart so
they've switched to crypto explain
crypto payments
and if they're doing it they're like the
whale that sort of drags the porn
industry around
if they're doing it then everyone else
will start following suit and if you see
the porn industry adopt and push the use
of crypto mainstream
the same way that porn caused dvds to be
adopted the same way porn caused camp to
be adopted
like internet and blu-ray all this stuff
was porn
pushed at first the same thing you can
see with crypto is that
my prediction is that porn is going to
be the thing that actually pushes
crypto into far more mainstream adoption
in england
man i i said that and i was like do you
think that the reason why
like crypto like like bitcoin is is
going through the roof do you think
that's because of the porn industry and
john's like i know there's lots of other
things market factors just that i'm like
but dude it happened right after the
part of settlement
you